[Music]  this week on Trump TV the Donald made a  Supreme Court pick the hype was real and  so were the ratings the two finalists  have both been summoned to Washington to  build suspense ahead of the announcement  Donald Trump plans to named his choice  during a live televised primetime  ceremony only Big D knew the winner  would it be Thomas thank you or would it  be Neal today I am keeping another  promise to the American people by  nominating judge Neil Gorsuch whoa the  Donald and I would like to ask judge  Gossage and his wonderful wife Louise to  please step forward there they come  here they come how about a little hug  for the Donald yes Chirk Chirk Chirk  Chirk trump has scored so was that a  surprise was it stay with us we'll be  right back  success by Trump captures the spirit of  the driven man won a masculine  combination of rich vetiver tonka bean  birch wood and must create a powerful  presence all day long also tried Donald  Trump the fragrance which is also real